[Musique]
bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver en direct sur figaro live vous
le savez on attend vos points de vue
pour alimenter nos débats dans cette
émission aujourd'hui on attend vos
points de vue sur lefigaro.fr et puis
sur youtube
et puis on vous posera quelques
questions également sur twitter elles
sont déjà en ligne vous pouvez y
répondre je relaierai vos réactions vos
commentaires et vos questions auprès de
nos invités et justement aujourd'hui
pour débattre nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir vincent trémolet de villers
bonjour vincent vous êtes directeur
adjoint de la rédaction du figaro est en
face de vous vincent nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir agile smadja bonjour
gilles vous êtes directeur de cabinet du
maire de nanterre je rappelle que
nanterre et la ville préfecture des
hauts-de-seine
merci à tous les deux d'être ici en
direct avec nous deux thèmes aujourd'hui
vous vous opposez ou en tout cas vont
vous permettre d'échanger vos points de
vue le premier concerne l'islamo
gauchisme un terme dont on entend
beaucoup parler depuis l'intervention
polémique de la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur frédéric vidal
on va y revenir
et dans la seconde partie de l'émission
nous parlerons qu'ovide bien entendu la
france fait face à une sorte de répit
les courbes montre en tout cas un
plateau depuis quelques semaines un haut
plateau certes mais les contaminations
se sont stabilisés même si elle demeure
à un niveau élevé et on s'interrogera
faut-il aller j'ai maintenant les
restrictions sanitaires je poserai la
question à mes invités mais vous pouvez
d'ores et déjà y répondre sur twitter et
sur lefigaro.fr
allez on commence avec la polémique
suscitée par les propos de la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur frédéric
vidal tout a commencé
tout a commencé dimanche dernier sur ses
news on les écoute moi je pense que
l'islamo gauchisme gangrène la société
dans son ensemble et que l'université
n'est pas imperméable universités fait
partie de la société
la ministre a de nouveau insisté sur le
sujet en annonçant mardi avoir demandé
au cnrs
un bilan de l'ensemble des recherches
qui se déroule en france pour distinguer
ce qui relève de la recherche académique
académique et ce qui relève du mil et du
militantisme j smadja je me tourne vers
vous la mise
de l'enseignement at elle eu raison
d'affirmer que l'islamo gauchisme
gangrène l'université française elle a
eu tort à 100%
elle a eu tort d'abord elle est ministre
elle est censée incarner les valeurs
républicaines c'est à dire elle est
censée incarner un pouvoir qui doit
rassembler les français qui doit pas
mettre de l'huile sur le feu et l'a au
contraire elle alimente un fantasme
je récuse totalement ce terme 10 le
mogho schisme parce que je considère que
ça n'existe ça ne correspond pas à une
vérité scientifique
ça ne correspond pas un domaine de
recherche ça ne correspond pas des
théories établi c'est un c'est quelque
chose qui a été inventée de toutes
pièces par des gens qui en fait se
servent des attentats terroristes et de
l'émotion légitime qu'ils ont créés en
particulier le dernier en date qui a
bouleversé une bonne partie de la france
c'est-à-dire l'assassinât du professeur
samuel bâti on se sert de ça pour aller
vers d'autres d'autres règlements pour
pour aller vers une stigmatisation d'un
certain nombre vous savez la contreverse
dans notre pays la contreverse
intellectuelles et scientifiques
elle a toujours existé à l'université
elle a toujours existé dans les années
80 90 il y avait des comptes revers sur
le révisionnisme à l'université de lyon
aujourd'hui il y en a une il ya des gens
qui défendent l'idée qu'il y aurait de
l'islamophobie en france je n'en fais
pas partie je considère qu'il y à la
persistance d'un racisme contre les
musulmans mais je n'appelle pas ça de
l'islamophobie et je pourrais expliquer
pourquoi ça c'est quelque chose qui a
toujours existé la controverse mais une
chose est là qu mais quel rapport
est-ce que cela a avec avec la lutte
contre le terrorisme
absolument aucun hélas la ministre vous
rendez compte la ministre des étudiants
des chercheurs des universités alors
qu'elle a elle a un ministère qui
aujourd'hui est une maison qui brûle
avec des dizaines de milliers
d'étudiants qui sont dans la précarité
qui sont dans la course on y reviendra
sur vos rendre compte qu aujourd'hui son
principal sujet d'intérêt c'est mounir
de la main sur cet aspect là et sur
cette priorité appelé jean france match
aller vous êtes directeur du cabinet
maire de nanterre je le disais il ya une
très grande fac à nanterre par militaire
qu'est ce qui se passe sur place vous
avez pas des remontées sur c'est sur ces
théories c'est le savez ce qui se passe
actuellement à l'université de l'inter
c'est qu'il y à des milliers d'étudiants
qui sont dans un état de dépression
morales qui sont dans l'isolément qu'ils
sont en train de basculer dans la
précarité
parce qu'ils ne peuvent plus travailler
parce qu'ils n'ont plus de quoi payer
leur loyer de payer leurs études
il y a dix jours à l'université de
nanterre il ya un jeune étudiant de 21
ans qui s'est suicidée et je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas vu la moindre trace d'un moment
d'émotion de la ministre des étudiants
alors à l'université de nanterre comme
ailleurs il y a des points de vue
différents sur la question de l'islam
sur le rapport à l'islam sur la place de
l'islam dans la société française
bien sûr qu'il y a des débats à
l'université de nanterre comme dans
toutes les universités de france
évidemment mais encore une fois est-ce
que est-ce que c'est dangereux d'avoir
des débats des controverses
eh bien vous savez il y a des gens qui
défendent un point de vue radicalement
inverse
gilles kepel et d'autres d'ailleurs que
vous accueillez régulièrement dans les
colonnes du figaro et je trouve ça tout
à fait ça légitime
la controverse fait partie de la de la
culture française ça n'est pas un
aveuglement de votre part par rapport à
une situation absolument pas absolument
pas non parce que je ne connais pas un
seul chercheur un seul universitaires
français qui défend qui a qui a justifié
les actes terroristes
je n'en connais pas un seul parent
vincent très bon et quel est votre
sentiment vous sur le constat que fait
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
est-ce que l'islamo gauchisme est une
réalité dans les universités françaises
que c'est une réalité
c'est dans le climat intellectuel je
pense que la ministre
par ses déclarations par sa volonté de
demander au cnrs d'aller faire des
recherches là dessus a commis à la fois
une maladresse d'expression est une
absurdité de décision mais je pense que
ce concept que la différence de ce que
vous venez de dire n'est pas un concept
qu'il faut c'est un concept qui a été
forgée sur des réalités sur des textes
et sur des textes qui viennent notamment
de la gauche est en tête un texte de
1994 fait par un militant trotskiste
britannique qui s'appelle le prophète et
le prolétariat et dans lesquelles il est
que l'islam radical est un mouvement
social et que l'on peut s'appuyer sur
l'islam radical pour pratiquer des
luttes sociales et c'est ça la
définition de l'islamo gauchisme c'est à
dire c'est le passage d'une robe gauche
radicale qui était athée qui était
laïque et qui se fait complaisante avec
l'islam parce qu'elles considèrent que
c'est la religion des dominés j'ai
repris la phrase de célèbres de michel
foucault dans le corriere della serra
c'est au moment de la révolution
iranienne de 1979 il écrit il n'est pas
besoin d'être voyons pour constater que
la religion ne constituait pas une forme
de compromis mais bel et bien une force
cette force qui pouvait soulever un
peuple non seulement contre le souverain
et sa police mais contre contre tout un
régime tout un mode de vie tout un monde
et il y à des intellectuels de gauche
pas tous mais y'en a qui considère que
l'islam est une force qui va et que
c'est un abandon la laïcité par une
partie voilà exactement et que cette
force qui va permettre d'abattre des
citadelles qu'il faut pour cette gauche
extrême attaque et qui sont le
capitalisme qui sont le christianisme et
qui sont israël puisque le quand père
andré taguieff force de concept
d'islamophobie ce moment de la deuxième
intifada
quand il ya une alliance entre une
certaine gauche et le combat des
palestiniens donc c'est une réalité
intellectuelle ensuite là où vous ferez
d'airé vidal se trompe c'est que d'abord
elle attaque la recherche et je pense
qu'elles ne s'attaquent pas un climat
c'est un climat qui existe à
l'université et j'allais dire et c'est
ce que dit gilles kepel ce que dit
bernard rougier qui a écrit les
territoires conquis lycée nuit c'est à
dire qu'avant les toits
ce que dit pierre henri tavoillot qui
est professeur à la sorbonne de
philosophie politique
ils disent le problème c'est plus que
les recherches qui ne qui refuse de
rentrer dans ce prisme de l'islamo
gauchisme et des luttes
intersectionnelle c'est-à-dire indigénes
isme études de genre des colonialismes
n'ont pas de bourse ne sont pas aidés et
sont en difficulté donc en fait c'est la
liberté de recherche qui est plus
attaquer plutôt que le fait qu'il y ait
énormément de thèses qu'ils soient faits
sur ce thème de l'islamo gauchisme et
c'est en ça qu'elle a été imprécises
c'est en ça qu'elle a été maladroite et
c'est en ça qu'elle a comment presque
elle a presque réhabiliter quelque chose
qu'elle voulait dénoncer par le fait que
son approche n'étaient pas renseigné en
fait sur un sujet qui exige attendez
j'ai juste quand vincent canton valérie
p
président de la région ile-de-france ce
matin chez nos confrères de radio
classique dit qu'il ya des courants très
puissant qui sont à l'oeuvre dans
certaines facultés est la raison oui
mais c'est courant il existe au moins
dans la recherche était bien dans les
thèses qui sont fournis ça existe mais
il y en a mais dans des possibilités de
nomination dans des groupes
d'associations d'étudiants dans le fait
je me souviens d'un professeur à limoges
qui s'est élevé contre la venue
d'aurillac beauté de jacques était donc
la patronne du patron patron indigènes
du parti indigéniste et il avait eu vécu
des vexations et incertain de
disqualification intérieur de
l'université pour cette prise de
position c'est ça ce climat mais ce que
ce que je mange ce que je ne comprends
pas c'est que la ministre demande une
enquête
oui mais une enquête pour des sites pour
déterminer quoi une enquête qui va dire
quoi qui va déterminer si on a le droit
en tant que chercheur de penser et de
travailler sur un sujet par exemple sur
la question du rapport avec la
colonisation
sur la question de la mémoire sur la
question de l'impact que la colonisation
peut encore créer dans l'identité des
jeunes issus de la diversité est ce que
c'est là dessus qu'elle va déterminer un
cadre qu'il faudrait ne pas dépasser ou
accepter mais ça c'est une régression
incroyable intellectuelle parce que ça
veut dire on va créer une espèce de
police de la pensée
et puis vous savez il y à un personnage
de l'état important qui a récemment
commandé un universitaire français
un chercheur un rapport sur la question
du colonialisme sur le passé colonial
sur les rapports entre les mémoires sur
le rapport qu'on peut avoir encore
aujourd'hui avec le passé colonial en
algérie
c'est le président de la république est
commandé ce rapport il l'a commandé un
chercheur un historien français benjamin
stora qui a fait effectuer un travail
remarquable qui aboutit à 22
préconisations eh bien vous savez ça et
j'approuve totalement ce qu'a fait
manuel macron en commandant ce rapport
ça c'est la preuve que heureusement que
nous avons une recherche intellectuelle
dans les sciences sociales qui est tout
à fait féconde qui est divers
c'est le président de la république
d'ailleurs la ministre elle a commis une
lourde erreur politique en faisant cette
sortie au moment où le président de la
république sur ces thèmes-là qui
sont en cause avait commandé ce rapport
est d'ailleurs il ne m'étonnerait pas
qu'après les élections régionales de
juin où il y aura sans doute à nouveau
une nouvelle équipe gouvernementale il
ne m'étonnerait pas que madame vidal ne
fasse ne faisant plus partie de l après
fait des déclarations il ya trois mois
disons que ça n'existait pas donc elle
elle a changé de pied même sur le fond
ensuite sur le rapport de commander ce
rapport au cnrs est doublement absurde à
bord c'est pas le travail du cnrs et
ensuite le cnrs a fait des déclarations
notamment par l'intermédiaire d'antoine
petit clin d'oeil un des dirigeants
disant qu'aujourd'hui la race devait
être le le comment dire le l'élément
d'entrée par lequel on réfléchit sur la
société donc ça veut dire qu'ils
rentrent dans les théories qui ne sont
pas islamo gauchiste mais qui sont des
théories racialistes l'identitarisme
très bien donc c'est pas à lui de faire
ça à mon avis le modèle s'il y avait un
modèle de rapport à faire c'est ce qu'on
a fait à l'école avec le rapport obin
sur la laïcité mais c'est à dire que
vous avez des gens dont c'est le métier
et on pourrait regarder par exemple
nombre de thèse en sociologie qui sont
faites sur un certain nombre de thèmes
et voir s'il ya une trop grande
importance sur un certain nombre de
thèmes et qui empêche la recherche de
s'exercer sur d'autres c'est ça qu'a les
limites qu'on pourrait faire mais moi je
crois que encore une fois c'est prendre
le problème à l'envers le problème que
dont souffrent les universitaires et ils
sont nombreux qui disent qu'il ya un
climat islamophobe schiste ou que les
luttes intersectionnelle les empêche de
travailler
c'est un problème de liberté académique
ils disent en gros on ne peut plus
exercer la controverse dont vous parliez
parce qu'il ya un certain nombre de
préalables qu'il faut donner et si on
les donne pas eh ben on n'a pas de
bourse
on n'a pas de poste on n'a pas de
possibilité d'exercer notre métier est
encore une fois bernard ogiez café les
territoires conquis de l'islamisme qui
est un des livres les plus sérieux sur
ce sujet a été financée par la région
ile de france parce qu'il n'a pas trouvé
de financement à l'université et c'est
ça c'est par là qu'il faudrait prendre
les choses
je termine simplement jean-françois
bronstein qui est prof à la sorbonne a
fait un papier ce matin chez nous dans
lequel il dit exactement ça il dit le
problème c'est la liberté académique etc
en fait la pression est faite de façon
diffuse par des groupes d'étudiants des
groupes parfois de profs qui veulent
installer sur un certain nombre de
thèmes qui sont toujours les mêmes c'est
à dire race identité genre une
oksa et si on sort de cette doxa et on
est disqualifié en tout cas le milieu
universitaire est en ébullition depuis
que la ministre
frédéric vidal a demandé cette enquête à
au cnrs la conférence des présidents
d'université s'est exprimé dans un
communiqué paru le 16 février elle y
parle en ces termes je cite l'islamo
gauchisme n'est pas un concept c'est une
pseudo notion dont on chercherait en
vain un commencement de définition
scientifique et qu'il conviendrait de le
laisser à l'extrême droite qui l'a
popularisé fin de citation vincent
trémolet est ce que faire appel à la
notion d'islamologie ce c'est pas de la
manipulation politique comme le renard
mais le lol moi ça me fait rire parce
que le concept scientifique d'islam au
gauchisme on peut le discuter
mais ce sont les mêmes qui ont fait du
privilège blanc de la fragilité blanche
des fat théorie des études de gens d'un
certain de choses des comptes de des
concepts du populisme un concept
scientifique quel est le concept
scientifique du populisme moi j'en sais
rien ville est discutable bon donc le
l'islamo gauchisme est un concept qui a
été forgé par pierre andré taguieff
qu'il n'ya pas du tout de l'extrême
droite qui est un chevènementiste etc
est le plus grand spécialiste des plus
grands spécialistes français de la
rhétorique antisémite et qui a vu
observer une alliance objective mais
acceptée par ceux là même qui l'ont
pratiqué entre l'islam radical et
certains mouvements sociaux c'est ça ça
ça c'est une réalité alors ensuite est
ce que c'est une réalité scientifique
exigent qu'on fasse des tests dessus je
ne dis pas que cette je ne dis pas que
cette hypothèse n'existe pas et je ne
dis pas qu un certain nombre d'êtres de
l'intellectuel français ne la partage
pas mais je dis d'abord qu donc le
considérer comme un simple slogan
politique comme le fait le centre
national de recherche scientifique pour
vous ça n'est pas que ça non parce que
islamo-gauchiste évidemment ses
destinées c'est aujourd'hui c'est devenu
une insulte c'est à dire quelqu'un qui
islamo gauchiste et pas quelqu'un qui
est qui épouse une thèse c'est quelqu'un
qui est un quasiment un complice des
terroristes c'est ça que ça veut celle
là où il ya un problème c'est que une
chose et je suis prêt a pas à parler sur
le fond du fait qu effectivement il ya
eu des glissements intellectuels qui ont
fait qu'on a confondu la défense d'un
certain nombre de deux classes sociales
ou de populations qui sont dans des
quartiers qu'ils sont
affronter à des discriminations à des
chômage massif et où on a confondu ça
avec le rapport à la religion sage
je pense qu'il ya un problème là dessus
et je pense qu'il faudrait en parler
mais aujourd'hui ce n'est plus du tout
ça aujourd'hui le terme islamo gauchiste
il est employé pour en gros nous dire
que finalement on n'a plus le droit de
s'indigner par exemple du fait que des
musulmans dans notre pays sont victimes
d'actes racistes
il ne faudrait plus le faire voilà ça
c'est aujourd'hui ça devrait être
interdit parce que sinon on va être
soupçonné de de ne plus être laïque de
ne plus être ceci ou cela et bien non je
suis désolé mais la lutte contre le
terrorisme
encore une fois la lutte contre le
terrorisme elle n'a rien à voir avec
l'islam au gauchisme donc vous pensez
qu'il ya un problème de clarification
aussi entre islam et islamisme qui n'est
pas suffisamment clair on mélange un peu
aussi doudou est venu le débat le débat
qu'on a aujourd'hui il vient de ce qui
s'est passé avec l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit
tout vient de là tout vient de là et
c'est là où il ya un problème c'est à
dire que par des glissements successifs
on considère que aujourd'hui les les
gens qui m'aiment ce dont vous parlez
qui porte un certain nombre de théories
qui sont très contestables
on considère que ce serait eux qui est
qui créerait en quelque sorte le terreau
d'actes d'actes du qui ont abouti à
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit et là je
m'inscris en faux contre ça la lutte
contre le terrorisme
c'est pas c'est d'abord une lutte qui
doit mobiliser la police le
renseignement la police antiterroriste
la surveillance pénitentiaire etc
eh bien vous avez quand même des
intellectuels je pense notamment à aller
très vite et au livre au livre de
d'emmanuel todd après je suis charlie
qui ont dénoncé la manifestation du 11
janvier comme une manifestation
islamophobe et qui est terrorisé le fait
que ce qu'il appelait la religion de
mahomet était celle des nouveaux damnés
de la terre donc qu'ils en ont fait un
complice des jeunes est reprise dans le
dit pas ça voilà mais je dis que c'est
un succès quand même un climat
intellectuel qui est qui est malsain il
comprend qu'on peut de façon tout à fait
démocratique et civique combattre et si
jamais il se développe de façon trop
importante hégémonique à l'université on
peut le souligner et on peut le dire et
faire et faire attention à ça ça a été
long je l'avais apportez vous citer
également d'autres théories
ce que l'âme est en soi porteur de
terrorisme etc
donc vous avez aussi vous avez aussi les
deux opposés c'est la fin de ce débat on
va passer au débat suivant juste avant
je vous livre quand même un certain
nombre de commentaires qui sont faits
par les internautes qui sont très
nombreux et j'aimerais vous voulez vous
en faire par gisèle sur youtube c'est
une minorité qui gangrène la majorité
mais qui commence à être puissante même
si tout le monde ne se lasse pas ou ne
se laisse pas piéger pardon cela crée un
climat délétère qui peut influencer les
plus fragiles et perturber le bon
fonctionnement des universités pas de 44
sur lefigaro.fr frédéric vidal a tout
mon soutien et a raison de dénoncer la
gangrène islamistes gauchistes dans nos
facultés paul sur youtube je pense que
si cette montée n'est pas freiné elle
mènera vers quelque chose de similaire à
l'afrique du sud des 20e et 21e siècles
on commence d'ailleurs à voir certains
effet apparaître procès en racisme
systématique montée de l'insécurité
discrimination positive
le mélomane le mélomane sur youtube on
en est plus malheureusement au stade de
la thèse l'islamo gauchisme
eh bien tu es bien une réalité présente
partout il faut le dénoncer général et
skype sur youtube ces débats entre
guillemets des colonialistes ont des
positions anti française non mixité
n'est romero racialisme tout cela est un
danger pour la société française
il va sur lefigaro.fr il n'y avait que
nos gouvernements qu ignorer cette
montée inquiétante cas mbh sur youtube
c'est un leurre pour nous faire voter
dans le bon sens nicole 0,6 sur
lefigaro.fr quand on voit qui a le droit
de faire des conférences et qui n'en a
pas le droit dire que ce constat est
faux et honteux et enfin yvette sur
youtube tout cela est bien pire que le
coc vide et bien justement le coville on
y va merci yvette pour cette transition
un débat sur le co vide on vous pose
cette question sur les réseaux sociaux
faut-il aller j'ai maintenant les
restrictions sanitaires qu'ovide acheta
kobe de 19
on c'est vrai qu'en france on en discute
en ce moment d'une possible réouverture
des musées mais là c'est l'incertitude
sanitaire demeure elle plane encore je
vous propose d'écouter ce que disaient
les piliers l'épidémiologiste didier
pittet ce matin sur france inter
on est dans une phase où on est dans un
plateau est un plateau stables
relativement élevé avec un nombre de
transmissions qui continue à se faire et
bien évidemment on est dans une sorte de
vigilance armé de manière à éviter
justement de devoir payer avec un retour
de l'épidémie à des taux plus élevés les
contaminations sont stabilisées mais
demeure à un niveau élevé on est je
crois à 25000 nouvelles contaminations
en 24 heures est ce que vous pensez que
la france fait face un répit avant un
boom épidémiologique
moi je pense que je pense que jolie et
je lis des chiffres et tous tous les
gens qui nous a les fameux spécialistes
savaient ce qui à longueur qui
monopolisent les antennes les fameuses
épidémiologistes virologues
infectiologues qui nous avait annoncé
qu'après noël ce serait horrible il y
aurait une explosion des contaminations
y en a pas eu
ah mais après le jour de l'an par contre
vous verrez ce sera terrible il y aura
une explosion il y en a pas eu
ella a presque le et la galette des rois
et le président de la république qui a
décidé et j'approuve totalement cette
décision de ne pas procéder à un nouveau
confinement les mêmes disait ça va être
ça va être une boucherie
ça va exposer de partout les hôpitaux
vont être débordé sein de ce ça ne s'est
pas privé c'est à dire que depuis
maintenant plus d'un mois
on est exactement au même niveau il ya
même une légère baisse de 10% si j'ai lu
voilà
approuvé la décision des macros pour
total de 1 seulement politique sinon
c'est pas un coup politique je pense que
c'est je pense que le prix à payer d'un
confinement était beaucoup trop élevé
par rapport à la réalité de l'évolution
de l'évolution de l'épidémie
aujourd'hui eh bien il ya un peu moins
de gens dans les hôpitaux qu'il y a qu
il y a dix jours voilà et donc je pense
que là le niveau d'action du
gouvernement doit être proportionnée à
la réalité de l'épidémie où pour le
moment
voilà et donc pour répondre à votre
question est-ce qu'il faut alléger un
peu le dispositif ou pas est-ce qu'il
faut alléger
moi je pense que oui donc ça veut dire
que le statu quo sur lequel on est pour
l'instant à depuis le 16 janvier dernier
on est on couvre feu avancé à 18 heures
au lieu de 20 heures sur tout le
territoire en étant effectivement dans
ce statu quo est ce que ce statu quo
doit être dur et où il faut il faut au
contraire la légère
c'est déjà un semis confinement en fait
un 18 heures mais moi je partage
absolument ce qui ce qui vient d'être
dit je pense que on a eu l'affrontement
entre deux visions une qui était une
vision de data de modélisation de
courbes et de projection et une autre
qui est une vision de la réalité du
moment
emmanuel macron a eu l'intelligence et
le cran de prendre cette vision là je
sais pas si c'était un coup politique
mais c'était le retour de la politique
c'est à dire c'est la politique qui dit
maintenant c'est nous qui décidons
et c'est pas vous les scientifiques qui
a été zappé texte à décrédibilise pas un
peu la parole descente mais écoutez
l'ont fait eux mêmes le bleu fin octobre
comme canton macron reconfirme pour la
deuxième fois il dit deux choses il dit
quoi que l'on fasse selon les
modélisations de l'institut pasteur
il y aura neuf mille personnes en
réanimation le 15 novembre
quoi que l'on fasse il y en a eu cinq
mille et il dit nous prenons cette
décision parce que nous risquons quatre
cent mille morts bon et les chiffres
sont dix fois moins important le 7
décembre la même institut pasteur publie
une projection talent que nous publions
dans le figaro dans lequel il dit le 15
décembre on sera en dessous des 5000 des
fameux 5000 contaminés par jour et donc
on pourra tout ré ouvrir mais je n'ai
rien n'est pas arrivé donc la mairie
l'embellie dans le côté négatif et dans
le côté positif est le président de la
république après des décisions d'une
extrême gravité
en fonction de ces projections comment
voulez vous qu'ils acceptent
aujourd'hui que les mêmes qui lui font
les mêmes projections et comme vous le
disiez qui disait après noël
après la galette des rois et après les
crêpes de la chandeleur il va y avoir un
effet et que cet effet ne vient pas
alors ce qu'il dit c'est que l'effet
viendra bombe à force d'annoncer qu'il
va neiger wepad le jour où il neige et
diront qu'ils ont eu raison
mais pour le moment le président de la
république tu as raison de naviguer à
vue
en regardant les chiffres on essayait
tout voir et puis si jamais il est
indispensable à un moment de faire un
confinement très rapide il le fera après
sur les restrictions
moi je pense que on ne peut pas
raisonner en disant oui non enfin c'est
à dire qu'il faut maintenant essayer de
mesurer ce qui est bureaucratique ce qui
est symbolique et ce qui est sanitaire
je prends un exemple très concret et qui
peut apparaître comme provocateur mais
un consensus scientifique pour expliquer
que le masque en extérieur sert à rien
vous allez demande à tous les états unis
au gisti dix apparitions à marcher ou
non quand les endroits sont regroupés ça
sert à rien bon alors peut-être qu'on le
garde parce qu'on regarde à l'intérieur
mais on peut pourrait réfléchir là
dessus on va pas brader passé de 4 ans
avec ça il ya un certain nombre de
décisions
les théâtres pourquoi un théâtre dans
lequel on se lave les mains on a un
masque il ya un siège sur deux serait
moins dangereux plus dangereux qu'un tgv
comprend pendant deux heures pour aller
où que le rer qu'on va les prendre
maintenant décompresser pense que c'est
une histoire de ventilation également
ben yahia peut-être une histoire de nos
créations mais il ya en tout cas on n'a
pas la peau il ya un certain nombre de
décisions qui sont prises et quand on en
parle avec des politiques et voulaient
faire sur ils vous disent je vous leur
dites mais sur le plan sanitaire et
disent non c'est pas ces feuilles gars
mais bon faut bien le faisait rire
d'elle elle s'est faite jusqu'à présent
si vous voulez on a fermé les cinémas
des théâtres les musées mais on n'a
jamais été capables de prouver que les
cinémas les théâtres et musées étaient
des foyers de contamination n'a jamais
pu le prouver
et donc pourquoi on ne ferait pas l'un
vers c'est à dire par exemple pourquoi
est ce que le gouvernement ne déciderait
pas qu'à titre expérimental dans une ou
deux régions
on décide l'ouverture des cinémas des
théâtres des musées pendant une semaine
quinze jours et on fait le bilan à la
fin des quinze jours si vraiment ça se
traduit par une augmentation des
hospitalisations en particulier en
réanimation
on arrête mais si on constate au
contraire que finalement ça n'a pas
grand chose et bien là on l'étend petit
à petit à l'ensemble du territoire
national mais je ne vois pas aujourd'hui
par exemple
amusez vous avez un masque vous ne
parlez pas vous regarder des tableaux
qu'est ce qui fait croire qu'on pourrait
être contaminé par les par les vives par
les personnages des tableaux qu'on
regarde on va être contaminés comme ça
les restrictions régionaliser en
fonction des zones on va dire les plus
vertes qui ont une idée qui pourrait
prendre effet recherché humains sont
souvent les lie à ses yeux il ya des
gens qui ont de la chance qu'ils sont à
la montagne qui sont devant des pistes
lucky bon moment papier et puis qui vont
descendre à ski
moi j'aimerais qu'on m'explique en quoi
le fonctionnement des remontées
mécaniques à partir du moment où ces
gens sont là et s'ils font attention
dans la queue sur un téléski il ya un
risque que j'aimerais qu'on ment comme
l'expliquait alors on peut me dire que
c'est parce qu'il y aura des accidents
et que donc essayer d accidents ça va
remplir des lits d'hôpitaux qui ne
seront pas utilisés pour locaux vides
mais y aura de toutes façons ces gens
sont partis et ils peuvent avoir des
accidents
donc là ça fait partie des décisions qui
rejoignent ce qu'on a appelé l'absurde
distance c'est-à-dire que elles ne sont
pas directement intelligibles sur le
plan sanitaire et je pense que ça fait
naître dans la population une défiance
qui est malsaine c'est à dire que
l'opinion se dit mais est ce que ces
interdictions ont un but réel autre que
de pouvoir dire nous avons pris cette
décision et comme ça nous nous sommes
couverts les nous avons montré que nous
étions des gens prudents donc je pense
qu'il faudrait beaucoup plus fin
peut-être territorialisée faire comme
vous dites des expérimentations il n'y
avait pas de masque et pas de gestes
barrières personne ne savait comment ça
marche et et cette étude ou dans lequel
il le reconnaît ni les restaurants
étaient fermés donc il prend les lieux
plus ou moins clandestins les lieux qui
ressemble bon ça me paraît quand même un
peu faible je pense aux restaurateurs
qui se disent peut-être comment vous
ferait qu'on ait des éléments un peu
plus concret pour nous dire pourquoi en
faisant des tables espacées avec pas
trop de gens on n'arrivait pas à ouvrir
on arrive à la fin de ce débat je suis
désolé il est 17h31 on est un petit peu
en retard sur la question qui vous est
posée sur twitter faut-il aller j'ai
maintenant les restrictions sanitaires
vous êtes 57% à répondre favorablement
et 43% à dire non majorité plus nette
sur youtube puisque à cette même
question vous êtes 78% à nous dire que
oui vous
et que ces restrictions sanitaires
souhaitent alléger quelques commentaires
d'internautes merci encore de les avoir
posté sur twitter 4 nous dit ouvrez les
restaurants laisser les professionnels
de la montagne travailler et traiter les
vrais problèmes à la racine donner des
moyens à la santé et rendez nous notre
liberté
pierre sur youtube il y a plein de lieux
où les précautions sanitaires sont
simples à faire appliquer comme les
cinémas les théâtres ou les musées
christian sur lefigaro.fr cela n'est pas
cela ne s'est pas produit puisque nos
habitudes ont changé
et enfin on citera jill sur youtube ce
couvre-feu à 18h ne sert à rien les gens
vont quand même boire un coup chez des
amis à 18 heures on ne peut pas faire
ses courses du coup on s'entasse tous
les samedis voilà ce sera le mot de la
fin
merci encore de nous avoir suivis merci
à nos invités d'avoir exprimé leur point
de vue en direct et on se retrouve
bientôt sur lefigaro.fr et en tout cas à
demain pour ceux qui suivent point de
vue
[Musique]